last time we covered how you can use
service level indicators to measure the
reliability of your services
and how to use service level objectives
to set reliability targets
but what metrics should you use to
accurately measure your reliability
today i'm going to show you how to use
out of the box platform metrics in
google cloud
to do just that welcome to engineering
for reliability with google cloud
[Music]
let's start by remembering that you want
to be able to express your service level
indicators or slis as ratios or
percentages
this allows you to normalize various
measures of reliability
and set reliability targets in a uniform
way across your services
generally slis fall into two categories
request based slis
measure the fraction of good units of
work against the total for example what
percentage of requests to an http
endpoint
were successful in a given time window
window-based slis
measure the fraction of time intervals
during which the service meets a
threshold of reliability
over a given time window now that you
know what you're after
which metric should you use do you start
writing custom telemetry to create them
now there may be scenarios where that
makes sense and we'll cover those later
in the series
but let's start with metrics that google
cloud services create for you
right out of the box let's start with a
specific example
here's a common architecture for web
application that uses a global load
balancer to distribute traffic to
multiple gke clusters
for this example you can use the metrics
created by the global load balancer for
both availability
and latency slis let's have a look at
how you can use service monitoring in
the cloud operation suite
to define a service and set an
availability slo for it
from the project dashboard let's go to
the monitoring menu and select services
there are a number of services already
created in this project let's create a
new one
we'll use a gke deployment as the basis
for our service definition
let's name our service and submit
now that the service has been created
let's define an availability slo for
it
the first step is to set the sli or
service level indicator
services defined by app engine istio
orientos recognize availability in
latency slis
automatically but we've defined a custom
service
so we have to select other as the metric
we then need to decide whether our sli
should be request based
or windows based we'll link to another
video that describes the difference
between two
and the episode notes but for now we'll
simply calculate a proportion of good
to total events using a request-based
sli
the next step is to select the metric
that we want to use as our sli
because the service is being provided by
an external load balancer we can use the
request count metric
we'll count all requests in a total
filter
and just those that return to 200 in a
good filter
note that this approach does include
potentially erroneous requests like
those that return the 404s
in the total filter and you should
carefully consider whether that's the
behavior you want
once we've made our selections here we
can evaluate the resulting graph to
determine whether the sli will be
properly evaluated
next we'll select the compliance period
for the slo
we want the evaluation period to be long
enough that we can meaningfully evaluate
and
allocate error budget toward engineering
work but not so long that the air budget
takes too long to recover from an
incident
we also recommend using rolling windows
for operational concerns rather than
calendar
to avoid issues with uneven numbers of
weekends for example
if you're just getting started a 28 day
rolling window is great
note that this is not the alerting
window we'll cover alerting on slos in a
future episode
now let's set a performance go for our
slo evaluate the sli
against the goal over the last hour and
click continue to finalize our setup
let's name our slo in a way that will
allow us to easily determine what it's
measuring
and create it
immediately we can see that we're
actually in the negative for error
budget for this particular service
this is because we're using a rolling
period so the service is evaluated over
the last 28 days
this is a new service and we simply
haven't had enough good traffic to the
service
to recover all of the air budget this
will change as our service serves more
and more traffic
so that's how you can use service
monitoring in cloud operations
to define a custom service and set an
availability slo for it using an out of
the box platform metric
if you have a request response service
that uses cloud load balancers
using metrics like request count is a
great way to easily define an
availability sli
and set a target using an slo but what
about a data processing pipeline
in this example you want to monitor how
long it takes for data flow to process
data elements in the pipeline this is
sometimes called a data freshness sli
dataflow captures this information as
two metrics system lag
measures how long it takes the entire
job to process messages
per stage system lag measures how long
it takes for a given step in the
pipeline to process messages
because our service isn't running on gke
we'll have to create a custom service
definition using the api
make a request to the services endpoint
in your project providing the service id
and display name
once the service is defined you can
create an slo for it
you can use the system lag metric that
measures how long it takes for the job
to process messages
as an indicator of freshness let's have
a look at how to do that
in service monitoring
this time let's start directly on the
services overview screen
our data pipeline service doesn't have
any slos let's create one now
because this is a custom service which
does not support default availability
and latency metrics
we'll use other as the metric type next
we'll select the windows based
evaluation type
the system lag metric measures how long
it takes data elements to make it
through our pipeline
this metric isn't tracked per element so
we don't have a way to count a ratio of
good events to total
so we'll need to use a windows based sli
where we'll track its average
over smaller windows and count the ratio
of those windows that meet our threshold
over our evaluation period
let's select the metric and specify our
window criteria
based on the historical data shown here
we can expect the average system lag to
be under 2 seconds
a 5 minute window is a great place to
start note that shorter windows will be
more responsive to changes
but could also result in a noisier
signal
now that we've configured our sli let's
define our slo
we'll again use a 28 day rolling period
and set a target of 99
this means that we expect 99 of our
five-minute windows
over a 28-day period to have an
average system lag of under two seconds
let's give our slo a good name
and see how our service is performing
we can now see how our sli has been
performing against our target
and how much error budget remains and
that's how you can set up a data
freshness sli for a streaming data
pipeline
you've now seen how to use platform
metrics to define slis and slos for
services that use load balancers and for
data pipelines
but what about cases where none of the
out of the box metrics work for you
one option that might is to use logs
based metrics
let's have a look at how to do that
using cloud logging cloud monitoring and
service monitoring
here's a service that emits a log entry
for every request that includes a status
code
successful responses include a 200
status code server errors include a 500
error status and so on
from these log entries we can create a
logs based metric that will count the
number of requests
the status label will allow us to track
successful requests
separately from failed ones
we can view the metric in metrics
explorer to confirm that it's working as
we expect
we're now ready to configure the sli for
our service from this metric
and set an slo for it let's go to our
services overview
select our service and create an slo for
it
because we're essentially using a custom
metric let's select
other as the metric type we'll create a
request based sli
because we'll want it to calculate a
ratio of successful requests to all
requests
let's select our metric to be used as
the sli
we'll count the total number of requests
by using the unfiltered metric
we'll count the number of good requests
by only counting those that return to
200.
let's have our slo evaluated over a
rolling 28 day period
with the target of 95 percent
now we can see how our sli is performing
against our availability target
and how much error budget we have
remaining in this evaluation period
and that's how you create an sli in slo
using logs based metrics
for joining me today in this episode
we'll look at how to use platform
metrics to define service level
indicators
and set service level objectives against
those we covered using load balancer
metrics for request response services
data flow metrics for data processing
pipelines and logs based metrics for
services that may not emit good slis out
of the box
you're now ready to start defining sls
for your own services
don't forget to like and subscribe to
never miss out on more engineering for
reliability with google cloud
see you soon